we are still in dallas we've been
already here for eight days and today is
milo's birthday we can't celebrate her
birthday how he was planning to but we
will try to make the best which we can
it's really crazy i wanted to have a big
party and with the hurricane this is
what we got of course you want to get a
big problem yeah of course any reason to
park differently milo's birthday party
is my party too right yeah
all right myla
are you ready for your birthday
do you want to put on your bib i have a
birthday treat for you oh that has a
birthday treat for you
i have your favorite food of all time
my favorite food i even know it is her
favorite food that will be her birthday
cake since she don't like the sweets
yeah
then she don't like the sweets look myla
you see what i have for you happy
birthday
[Music]
happy birthday to you oh my god happy
birthday dear my name is
[Music]
does that taste good mama will buy for
your nice cake maybe one day but when
everything will get to normal this is
your hurricane cake
it's so sad that kids having cheeses for
a cake i know i know
y'all and i have been doing pretty good
lately you know but anybody in our
position we have obstacles having a baby
in another country for her was very hard
she hasn't been able to travel home to
see her family she's still waiting for a
green card we'll go home i'm hoping
really to find my my green card
interviews coming soon so the paper
should come my green card was delayed
already so many times and i was delayed
again
i really need my green card because with
my green card i will be able to go home
and see my mom because my allergies get
one year old and my mama still doesn't
serve her that's so upset and i'm
waiting for that so much bad thing i'm
the most worried about is how long is
the green card off is going to be closed
for now
that was in new orleans i don't know how
much damage they had maybe this is what
you are yeah yeah if they have
significant damage they don't have power
for a long time then that's just going
to delay you getting
[Music]
you